dans quelques semaines
saint-quentin-en-yvelines devra voter le
budget 2010 8 mai avant la présentation
du rapport d'orientation budgétaire est
une étape obligatoire
il permet aux élus de prendre
connaissance des contraintes financières
de l'agglomération première révélation
une baisse de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement de 35 millions d'euros
depuis 2014
si on projet jusque 2020 ce sera 50
millions et si on va jusqu'à des
projections de 2023 on peut aller
jusqu'à près de 100 millions donc quelle
est la structure plus public ou
intercommunal chi qui peut résister à ça
c'est quand même c'est en rendant une
face comme très difficile pour cette
année 2010 8 il manque 13 millions
d'euros pour boucler le budget parmi les
pistes évoquées une mutation
institutionnelle
la réorganisation des services ou encore
une révision de la politique fiscale
moi je m'interdis rien mais c'est pas ce
serait pas ce serait pas un bon choix on
n'a jamais augmenté les impôts depuis
que nous sommes à la tête de cette
interco franchement c'est pas c'est pas
un choix c'est plutôt nous le dvq le
développement économique faire des
économies aussi restreinte peut-être des
investissements bien sûr un peu plus
serré tous les budgets
c'est plus edf cela qu'on se dirige on
va regarder avec beaucoup d'attention la
question des services à la population
n'a au de nouveaux services dans cette
agglomération et on tient ce que ça soit
maintenue et que d'autres projets
d'autres sujets plus en plus annexes ne
soit pas privilégiée donc on revenir aux
fondamentaux de ce à quoi doit servir
l'agglomération c'est à dire rendre des
services aux habitants de 50 ans
prochaine étape pour les douze communes
qui composent saint quentin en yvelines
se réunir autour de la table pour faire
des choix
trois rendez vous sont programmés avant
le vote du budget en avril